MICHEL DEGRAFF: So,
yes, this course is--
the core of it is discussions.
And in order for the
course to be successful,
we have to be able to discuss
very delicate, personal issues
in a very safe way
and to be honest.
It cannot be that students
are afraid to reveal
their positions on various
topics including race,
language, identity.
And one way to do
it is to, given
that I had at the very
beginning of the course,
I had the questionnaires
about where they came from,
what languages they
spoke, where they grew up,
I was able to use that
to trigger discussions.
So if we read a text about
authenticity, for example,
if you are an African, can
you be an authentic writer
if you write in
English, for example?
Then I knew that
some of the students
had dealt with this issue.
For example, we
had a student who,
although she was
Black and Hispanic,
but she wasn't very
fluent in Spanish.
And she wasn't clear whether
her not being fluent in Spanish
made her any less Hispanic.
You see, so I could--
I was able to use that in order
to trigger a discussion around
this notion that we had read
in the famous debate between
Chinua Achebe and Ngugi wa
Thiong'o about African writers.
Can an African-- can a writer
be authentically African
if they write in English
or French for that matter?
So that was one way to
trigger rich discussion,
by taking a text that
connected to these issues
and making it personal.
So the motto there
was rich discussions
are best arrived at if they
stem from a personal basis
where students are
invested in trying
to find an answer
that can work for them
in their personal lives.
Or in the lives
of their families,
their communities,
their countries, etc.
So that was the
one key technique.
And then, there was
another condition for it,
to have these discussions.
It's to have mutual
respect and trust.
Because, in these questions,
there cannot be a right
and wrong answer.
So it is based on your own level
of comfort, what, you know,
choices you've made
your personal life,
for your identity.
And we have to be able to
accept different opinions.
But sometimes,
that was not easy.
Because they were,
like in the class,
there was another student
who spoke Spanish fluently
and will view
himself as Hispanic.
And there was
another student who
didn't speak
Spanish so fluently,
who also view
herself as Hispanic.
So right there, there
was a potential for who
was more Hispanic, you see.
But yet, they are both Hispanic
in their own ways, you see.
And this is where the debate
gets very interesting.
How do you define
being Hispanic?
And then we are back to
that very core question.
Who belongs?
Who doesn't belong?
And this is where, again,
language and identity
become tools for either
inclusion or exclusion.
And since the course is
eventually about inclusion,
then how can we use these
different identities to create
a space where one can
have a sum that's much
larger than the parts, you see.